it's summer in Australia and this
orchard would usually draw hundreds of
visitors who come to pick their own
fruit this is just one of many small
businesses devastated by the bush fires
almost all these apple trees were
destroyed by flames the trees were
uninsured and it will cost the family
about 1 million dollars to replant them
and repair the damage
my parents have owned it for in the
business for 35 years and yeah it's it
takes a bit of a toll emotionally when
you say you put so much blood sweat and
tears into producing the fruit and to
see it go up in flames it's just
devastating many farms around Australia
had already been suffering through the
relentless drought and this bushfire
season has just made their situation so
much worse but the financial impact of
this natural disaster won't just be felt
on farms it will be felt around the
country this is Australia's longest
bushfire emergency the fires began
months earlier than normal and are still
burning the most severely affected areas
only account for about 1% of the
Australian economy but the disaster is
having a global impact we'll also see a
loss of tourism coming into this country
people are already canceling holidays
and whether there's a longer term costs
associated with the image of Australia
as a burning nation analysts have
downgraded forecasts one of Australia's
biggest banks Westpac estimates it could
slash half a percent from economic
growth already there are around 1
billion dollars worth of insurance
claims and the government has committed
around one-and-a-half billion dollars to
rebuilding infrastructure but it says
there could be more money if it's needed
scientists say the bushfire season has
been exacerbated by climate change and
that's put Australia's leaders under
more pressure to raise targets to reduce
carbon emissions but coal is one of
Australia's biggest exports and prime
minister Scott Morrison has said
although policies could be evolved he
won't engage in what he called reckless
job destroying targets the government
has indicated there may be a formal
inquiry into the fires including any
role climate change may have had in
sparking one of Australia's most
expensive natural disasters ever jessica
washington al jazeera bill pin australia